the point to bring out here is that if
you look at for example a given
protected area and you look at the
actors that benefit from it and pay for
it at different scales say a local scale
and national scale on a global scale the
benefits and the costs they each receive
are very different so that these are
just a luster tube but you can see that
they aren't the same and a couple of
really important generalities can be
drawn out of this the first is that very
often costs are focused while benefits
are dispersed that the classic Circuit
case this would be carbon Community or
government has to pay the opportunity
cost of not using a forest for logging
or for agriculture if they want to
protect the carbon value that's some of
the global community benefits from
another another sort of common
generality here is that costs are often
short term while benefits are longer
term this would be the case for example
in creating a marine protected area to
manage fisheries we're asking in that
case for fishermen to forego a catch in
the present presumably for a greater
catch in the future and the final
perhaps not so common but important
generality to draw it is that coughs
cost I very often quite a bit more
palpable than the benefits so if a lion
kills your cow and it's one of your
three cows or if monkey eats your crop
that's an immediate fiasco and it's much
more palpable even if the value in
economic terms is sort of the same then
all the little bees that are fertilizing
the grass that the cow eats and all the
beetles that are digesting the nitrogen
so anyway so and so it's perceived
differently even if a sort of economic
number adds up the second sort of set of
points here is the importance of working
at the margin and I don't know how many
of your economists but I I mean that in
the economic sense of the word that is
the the difference in for example
certain amount of investment to
protected area the marginal difference
of adding one more unit of that or
taking it away rather than something
that's sort of working on something
that's irrelevant which is maybe the
common understanding of that word and in
that area are sort of three points to
add well 11 is the need to be careful
extrapolating the thing that got some of
the people's hackles raised when Bob
Costanza published his serve seminal
work in 1997 about this about ecosystems
services was that he'd extrapolated from
site specific values to sum total of
areas that might
include that might have those services
so say from one kilometer of beach but
you may have a 50-dollar value of
tourism to all the beach in all the
world which should have fifty to fifty
dollars times the total number and
there's a potential error there because
our services can go up or down depending
on how the pattern looks the second
point to start bring out here in regard
to the margin is a need to include echo
system services from the productive
landscapes one of the sort of easy
things to overlook is that is to serve
say protected areas have the following
ecosystem services and production
landscapes of the falling production and
that's the comparison but in reality
there's quite a bit of value of echo
system service from production
landscapes as well and it's important to
take that into account and the final
point here I think is at the very least
to be transparent about the difference
between total and marginal value I have
sort of bias here about thing that total
value is actually a sort of a deceptive
thing to say and at all but but to very
least be transparent about it starting
by just adding in one ecosystem service
to what you'd otherwise think of as the
serve market values of the land timber
and AG you get a straightforward sort of
result that carbon value exceeds that
that with carbon value that green snare
exceeds the value of the business is
usual scenario if you add back in
management costs business as usual
starts to win and if you add back in
this this somewhat undefined bundle of
good things that people perceive as
coming from these protected areas that's
based on a willingness to pay study
again green looks like a good choice for
this region maybe the interesting bit is
to sort of bring out some of the
complexities and doing this even though
that looks so straightforward one of
them would be to note that management
costs well it's a cost is also something
that benefits the local economy some of
it maybe most of it not all perhaps goes
to hire local people goes to buy stuff
from the local economy and so it has to
serve up here in both columns another
interesting another interesting thing to
consider is that local value from
agriculture it may be actually closer to
the gross return than the profit that is
the standard assumption would be to say
the value of Ag is the profit these guys
earn this much the rest is their cost
but in fact again many of those costs
happen
Quilly those guys are buying their
inputs locally they're hiring people
locally to work in the farm and so on
and that suggests that those value
should go up as you as you as you try to
do a better job of this analysis the
third point is a key one and one that
has served repercussions throughout this
but that that the negative welfare
impact of carbon emissions is much much
higher than what ends up being monetized
in what sort of exists already the
voluntary market that is the cost to
society of each ton of carbon is much
more than what's being paid now per ton
and if you go with inflated estimate
from the stern report it's something
like thirty five dollars per ton rather
than seven or deaf or I think has a
similar number and that's important
because that's a difference in what
society gets versus what what gets
locally even if a transaction happens
which isn't happening in most cases I
think as we think about using these
sorts of tools it's very important to be
honest about the generation of economic
arguments for protected areas i think
the world you know especially in the
wake of t biz is quite open to this sort
of stuff but at least in many of the
developing countries the quality of data
available is pretty poor and people are
willing to accept fairly rough analysis
I and in particular for example that
issue of total benefit versus marginal
benefit one that often gets confused and
so I think I think it's quite important
to be clear about what we're producing
and be clear about it to decision makers
even if it's a bit more complex because
otherwise I think things are going to
come around and bite us and we'll be
accused of sort of snake oil sales over
time I think that's a mistake keep an
eye out for four cases where the public
good isn't the objective of decision
makers so so all of these sort of
generate arguments that say if you
created this protected area here and
somebody shared a benefit with somebody
else and you manage this way society
would be better off the local people
would have a better livelihood the
country would protect its natural
heritage in the world would gain some
carbon but but very often maybe every
where that isn't how decision-makers are
making their decisions they're making
decisions based on who their friends are
based on their sort of worldview based
on constituencies and and all of those
things you know the classic example is
being the massive amount of subsidies
that go in all sorts of funny directions
are clearly aren't in the public good
and our bad investments of scarce
government money but they happen anyway
so it's good I think as we think about
sort of choosing to generate economic
arguments to understand who we think
we're good influence and whether they're
going to care because they're quite a
lot of places where we could waste some
good bullets going down this path